by the way just just out of curiosity
what was harder to do
was it was it tougher to give up a
heroin or was it tougher to lose the
weight which one was tougher and were
both motivations the same is it like
fear of death is it is it a girl in your
life is it family is it i just got a
change is it a spiritual moment what
what was it what were the differences
well i i i think about it in different
ways i think that um
drugs
are not easy to give up but it's a kind
of a black or white thing for me and
this is not necessarily for everyone but
for me
i am an addictive person so i have to be
all or nothing i'm either using drugs
and
very quickly heading to death or i'm not
and i'm very quickly heading to a
healthier happier life you can't dabble
at all you're zero or i cannot that's
just your dna no i don't have a glass of
wine on new year's or anything like that
the the the problem with stuff like
heroin is and it's not super
widely widely talked about it's like the
thing that i liked about it was it
actually changed my brain chemistry
right so
whatever um a sense of happiness you get
from
uh succeeding at a goal you set for
yourself
or or anything right is now being
given to you by this drug so when you
stop taking it your body doesn't know
how to do that so i was
you you have these ex junkies who are
perpetually depressed for years it takes
a long time for your body to get back to
normal it's not just like
get it out of your system and you're
fine right you're constantly thinking my
happiness whether it's uh
subliminal or or or or
you know you might not be having these
these thoughts analytically but
the the sense is like i cannot function
like a normal person without this stuff
because
your body doesn't react any longer like
a normal person so it takes a long time
to build those systems back up
the difference with food is
you can't be black or white you cannot
just quit eating you have to eat or
you're gonna die right so it's actually
way more complicated it's a lifetime
uh process there is no goal that i get
to this weight and i'm done that does
not exist for me with food
and
while i i want to think about drug use
also as a lifetime process it gets to be
so as long as you're not doing it you
know i'm not my wife drinks alcohol i am
never tempted to have a glass of wine
with her ever
i wouldn't go sit in a bar by myself i
wouldn't do that i'm not going
back to some dude's hotel room to watch
him do cocaine that's not something i
would ever put myself in that situation
right but i have to eat and so every
night while i'm eating and i'm
regulating what i'm eating there is that
thing that's you know under the surface
of like put more oil on it put more
sugar on it you know
double your portion so that's a that's a
more difficult thing i think to deal
with long term have you have you gotten
it to a point where food is now just
it's not you know like yesterday we were
eating with david berlinski i take him
to casa de angelo and i'm like uh so
what's your favorite food i eat the same
thing every day that can't be no i eat
the same thing every day what do you eat
for breakfast two egg whites two egg
whites and and sometimes so what do you
eat for lunch i eat uh you know protein
whatever and i would eat for a a dinner
burger every hamburger i said every day
he says i care less what he ate i don't
know we're at the nicest italian
restaurant what do you want i don't know
octopus i've never had it before you've
never had after you're 80 years old he
lives in paris yeah he says no you don't
need any of the questions so has food
for you because one connection some
people make that that i it's i think
it's very interesting you know i'm a
foodie oh you know oh my god we gotta go
eat some sushi we gotta go some and he
mentions like yeah food is not one
my method of entertainment food is not
no longer for me like i'm looking
forward to it it's just what my body
needs to eat and it's become very
regimented is that the distinction you
had to make that's what i try to do now
listen i too
love to eat and i think that as i got
healthier and tried to take more
responsibility with how i interact with
food i became way more interested in
very specific types of food like i flew
to um
china once to eat peking duck at this
little uh luquan roast duck it's in an
alley and it's like the the best peking
duck on earth apparently like i've done
stuff just went to china for that to eat
come on i got the duck i'm out yeah
you know and then i i also ate you know
skewered scorpions that were fried on
the street and stuff like that like i'm
interested in food in that way
but
it there's i'm you know the thing i've
the thing i've also found is i i do eat
mostly the same stuff right
all the time i always have whey protein
and water for breakfast that is what i
eat for breakfast every day and water
and water not milk although i will say
there's this new um
fair life protein drink that's 30 grams
of protein and i think it is made with
well milk and i believe whey protein
comes from milk so there's that but i
don't put almond milk or anything like
that in my protein with my protein
powder um
you know moderation i think is the key
to winning for the rest of my life so i
don't want to cut off everything and say
you know if i'm in rome i'm not going to
eat the pasta dish that i love right i
can't do that but i'm going to have that
one time
and then the rest of the time that i'm
in rome i'm going to eat the way i eat
normally which is fish or meat and
vegetables
what's your favorite food like if you
were to say my favorite favorite food is
like i would say it's horme sabzi it's a
persian stew what's your favorite food i
mean if i was going to say my favorite
iranian food i would say tadiq oh and i
would want something really juicy to
pour on it you know what i mean never
been to rafi's place
is that in glendale yeah yeah yeah the
owner is my best man at my wedding
really yeah it's great food yeah
phenomenal food yeah the best yeah so
what's your favorite though what's your
favorite food my favorite is tied up
somehow with this memory of when i was
five and i showed up at my grandparents
house in vermont and they said god
you're so fat you're going on a diet and
my grandfather cooked what i remembered
being my favorite meal which was lasagna
and they gave me
they said you get this
paper thin slice and so for the rest of
my life i was like that's my favorite i
don't think it really is
at five years old because i've read this
before that you're that it's kind of
triggered where you're at with all your
weight loss
i don't want to blame them i just i
don't think they i don't think they
really
you know their intentions were good and
clean
but you know also honestly if they were
the same age today
and looked at the landscape of childhood
obesity they would have been like you
are fine
how how heavy i was at five i was a
chubby five-year-old i wasn't an obese
five-year-old but they were shocked at
my appearance and put me on this crazy
diet and then convinced my parents to
put me on diets for the rest of my
adolescence i i would say my favorite
food the food that i've eaten the most
in the past 10 years is lebanese
lebanese is my favorite food lebanese
it's very clean you can get a healthy
meal it's not got a bunch of other
garbage in it
i saw the the three-hour podcast you did
with rogan yeah and the first hour you
guys just went in on food and dishes and
this and and pat just literally had how
many dinners did you have with rogan
this past weekend we were together for
uh friday night and saturday night until
like four o'clock in the morning date
dinners though
cal fort steakhouse oh my and we ate
like at three in the morning so imagine
eating a fat steak at three o'clock like
that's not that's the worst thing you
can do we went to sleep yeah
yeah yeah but you you guys went off
about how he said i could just eat steak
and vegetables and that's it i'm good to
go yeah but pasta like we had pasta and
steak last night
well yeah but see there's even there's a
there's a universe now that the the
landscape of of diets and diet fads gets
really crazy so for a long time i was
convinced if i just don't eat carbs i'll
lose weight and i'll be fine but it got
to the point where because i can over
eat and and that is really my
predilection is to over consume i'll
overeat steaks i'll eat 5 000 calories
in a steak and only burn 3 000 calories
that day and actually gain weight so
that's not
that's not a good um
solution for me so is it more important
to portion control or eat healthier for
me okay there could be a guy who's out
there who won't eat 5 000 calories in
steaks and all he has to do is cut carbs
out of his diet and he'll be fine that's
possible you see this kid over here on
your left that guy carb loads right like
he's like
he eats a sandwich with the bread as the
as the meat and then more bread i'm like
what are you doing he gets the club
sandwich and removes the turkey exactly
yeah
talk some senses
when you're 23 years old that works when
you're 33 you're going to be a fat ass i
got to enjoy it while i can if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]